La seconde moitié de la nation mooc est devenue une force, et le corps d'un lieutenant-colonel
Je l'ai fait trois fois avec celui qui m'a donné un journal de porcelaine.
tu dois sortir
Zheng Dan, président d'ERP, a insisté sur le 7ème départ
Changé en ministres et salles basés sur la carte afin
jolie couleur du navire principal en direct
[taper]
pour
Nos 1 000 000 camarades multi-gagnés brûlent le cœur de l'ère patriotique
Cependant, le Parti des travailleurs coréens, qui a été préparé et élevé en toute sincérité,
5 ans de développement économique national environ période de mise en œuvre 2
C'était fini jusqu'à l'année dernière, mais l'objectif fixé était de réaliser d'énormes Mina dans presque tous les domaines.
Des principes, à ce congrès du parti, qu'il vienne des institutions religieuses ou non, l'expérience et la douloureuse Birmanie
Analyser et purifier les personnes âgées de manière globale et approfondie